- [Voiceover] So we've got a writing
and language passage here,
it's called, "A Life in Traffic."
All right, let's just get into it.
A subway system is
expanded to provide service
to a growing suburb.
A bike-sharing program is adopted
to encourage non-motorized transportation.
Stoplight timing is
coordinated to alleviate
rush hour traffic jams in
a congested downtown area.
When any one of these changes occur,
it is likely the result
of careful analysis
conducted by transportation planners.
So that felt a little
off, let's just read it
a little bit more carefully.
When any one of these changes,
so they are talking about
the individual changes,
they're not talking all of
these changes at the same time.
So if you're saying any
one of these things,
you have a singular
subject right over here.
So the verb should match
that singular subject.
But they have occur, if you
said all of these changes,
then you would say occur.
iIf you're talking about
the plural, many changes,
what are they doing?
They occur.
But if you're saying any one
change, it doesn't occur,
a single thing occurs.
This needs to be the singular form.
If that one change occurs, not occur.
So this should be occurs.
So let's look at the choices.
So, both of these are
occurs, this one says
when any one of these
changes occurs, they are,
well we're talking about any one change,
so you shouldn't refer to it
as they for any one change.
Remember, if you said when
all of these changes occur
then you could have said they are.
But if you are saying any one, once again,
you're only referring
to one of the changes,
it occurs, then you
should refer to it as, it.
So right there.
When any one of these changes occurs,
it is likely the result of
careful analysis conducted
by transportation planners.
We're now in the second
paragraph of "A Life in Traffic."
The work of transportation
planners generally includes
evaluating current transportation needs,
assessing the effectiveness
of existing facilities,
and improving those facilities
or they design new ones.
All right, that felt a little bit off,
so let's think about
what's happening here.
They're listing a bunch of stuff,
they're listing what is
included in the work of
transportation planners.
So the work of transportation
planners generally includes,
and then the first thing is evaluating
current transportation needs.
Then assessing the effectiveness
of existing facilities.
And improving those facilities,
or they design new ones.
So right over here when we're
listing the different things,
we see the first several
things in our list,
we have evaluating, the fancy
term for something like this.
This is a gerund, and this is a verb.
You put an -ing at the end
of it, it becomes a noun.
The verb, to evaluate, well
now we're talking about
the action of evaluating.
So that's a gerund.
Then we have it again, assessing.
And then we have improving.
And then, if you want this
sentence to be constructed
in a natural way, instead of they design,
you would want the gerund form of design,
which is designing.
Now let's see how that sounds.
The work of transportation planners
generally include evaluating
current transportation needs,
assessing the effectiveness
of existing facilities,
and improving those facilities,
or designing new ones.
That sounds a lot better.
If you wanted to be even
clearer, you can just
think about these gerunds themselves.
The work of transportation
planners generally includes
evaluating, assessing, and
improving or designing.
You have a nice parallel
construction, it's called then.
That all of the things that you're listing
are in the same form.
So this should definitely
be designing, designing.
And if we look here, luckily
that is one of the choices.
We're now on question
three right over here.
And, if you're under
time pressure in the SAT,
you might want to think
about going straight
to the sentence that includes
question three in it.
And different people might
have one different style.
Some people might want to
read all of the context
to kind of keep up with the passage.
It depends on how fast you might read.
But a lot of these you might be able
to jump straight and be able
to go straight to the question.
So, let's do that first,
then we can go back
and see if reading this
actually helped us.
If analysis of the traffic
count indicates that there
is more traffic than the current road
as it is designed at this time,
yeah that sounds a little strange,
can efficiently accommodate,
the transportation planner might recommend
widening the road to add another lane.
So they're really just saying if analysis
of the traffic count indicates
that there's more traffic
than the current road can accommodate,
that the current road can
efficiently accommodate.
So really, maybe you don't need any
of this stuff right over here.
Let's look at the choices.
So no change, no, I
definitely want to change it.
The way it's written right now is
way more complicated
than it needs to sound.
It's very hard to understand.
Current design of the road right now.
If analysis of the traffic
count indicates that there is
more traffic than the current
design of the road right now.
Yeah, that right now feels unnecessary.
If analysis of the traffic
count indicates that there is
more traffic than the road as
it is now currently designed
can efficiently accommodate.
Yeah, that's a little bit wordy still.
So, this one, this one actually,
if analysis of of the traffic
count indicates that there is
more traffic than the
current design of the road
can efficiently accommodate,
the transportation planner
might recommend widening the
road to add another lane.
Yep, this is definitely the one.
You know if I didn't look at the choices,
similarly you could say the current road
can efficiently accommodate.
But you could also say the
current design of the road
can efficiently accommodate.
Makes this a much, much cleaner,
easier to understand,
easier to understand sentence.
Now that we've done that,
let's just read the,
you obviously would not
have time to do this
if you were taking the SAT.
But let's just think about
what the rest of it said.
Most transportation planners
work in or near cities,
but some are employed in rural areas.
Say, for example, a large factory is built
on the outskirts of a small town.
Traffic to and from that location
would increase at the beginning
and end of work shifts.
The transportation
planner's job might involve
conducting a traffic count to determine
the daily number of vehicles traveling
on the road to the new factory.
If analysis of the traffic
count indicates that there
is more traffic than the
current design of the road
can efficiently accommodate,
the transportation planner might recommend
widening the road to add another lane.
So, all of this the sentences in between
question two and question three,
it's nice, it gives you context
for why some transportation planners
might have to deal with stuff that's in
more rural areas, which is
where there's a factory.
And that's actually the
context for having to analyze
the traffic as people go to and from work.
But, you actually didn't
need to read all of this
in order to answer this
question right over here.
So, we're now onto question four.
Transportation planners work closely
with a number of community stakeholders,
such as government officials and other
interested organizations and individuals.
Next, representatives from
the local public health
department might provide
input in designing a network
of trails and sidewalks to
encourage people to walk more.
So, next definitely feels like
a strange word to put there.
In this first sentence, and
I do think it was necessary
to read this first sentence here.
Because this, whatever
we put here is, I think,
going to connect that first
and the second sentence.
So, the first sentence is talking about
transportation planners that work
with other stakeholders,
such as government officials,
and other interested
organizations and individuals.
Now here, they talk about
representatives from
the local public health department.
This looks like an example.
So I would say something like,
For example, representatives
from the local public health
department might provide
input in designing a network
of trails and sidewalks to
encourage people to walk more.
So, let's see what the choices give us.
We definitely don't want to say no change.
Well, for instance.
This is like saying "for example".
"For instance", it's
giving an actual instance,
an actual example of transportation
planners working closely
with a community stakeholder.
"Furthermore", this isn't
extending what was said
in the first sentence.
It's giving and example of it.
Once again, "similarly",
it's not saying something
that is like what the first sentence said.
It's giving an actual example
of what the first sentence said.
So, it's definitely B, for instance.
For instance, representatives
from the local
public health department
might provide input
in designing a network
of trails and sidewalks
to encourage people to walk more.
Members of the Chamber of
Commerce might share suggestions
about designing transportation
and parking facilities
to support local businesses.
So, that was another
example right over there.
All right, let's go on to question five.
Now, on question five.
People who pursue careers
in transportation planning
have a wide variety of
educational backgrounds.
That actually feels pretty good.
I don't know if I would
change that at all.
But let's see what the other choices are.
People, who pursue careers
in transportation planning,
have a wide variety of
educational backgrounds.
Well, when you put these commas around
"who pursue careers in
transportation planning,"
it makes it looks like hey, that's just,
that's something that
doesn't have to be part
of the sentence.
It's a, sometimes people say
it's a non-restrictive clause.
It's a clause that doesn't,
kind of tells you another way
of thinking about people.
It's an optional thing.
But, for this sentence,
we couldn't just say
people have a wide variety
of educational backgrounds.
Even though that is true.
People do have a wide variety
of educational backgrounds.
That's not what the
meaning of the sentence is.
It's very important that we
talk about what type of people.
People who pursue careers
in transportation planning.
So, I guess one way you could call it,
is this is a very important
restrictive clause
for the sentence.
You need to know what type of people.
That is key to the
meaning of the sentence.
So, I wouldn't put commas around it,
which makes you feel that
it's hey, this is optional.
It's another way of describing the people.
And maybe you could just read,
People have a wide variety
of educational backgrounds.
So, I don't like this.
I think for the meaning
that we are trying to give,
the writer is trying to give,
it is very important that you have
"who pursue careers in
transportation planning,"
not have commas.
Once again, that commas
make it sound like yeah,
it's just another way
of describing people.
Not essential necessarily to
the meaning of the sentence.
But this is essential to
People who pursue careers,
in transportation planning,
have a wide variety of
educational backgrounds.
Well, this is kind of
doing something similar.
Now they're just putting
"in transportation planning"
in commas.
And one way to think about that is
you could say,
People who pursue careers have
a wide variety of educational backgrounds.
Well that's a true statement,
but this whole passage is about people
who pursue careers in
transportation planning.
You don't want to, just
like we said for B,
you don't want to mark this off,
you don't want to mark
this off with this clause
making it seem like this
clause is kind of optional.
You need to say "in
transportation planning."
So I wouldn't put commas around it.
And then finally,
People who pursue careers in
transportation planning, comma,
have a wide variety of
educational backgrounds.
Well that just feels,
we just taking kind of
the subject of the
sentence and separating it
from the predicate of
the sentence with a comma
for some reason.
So that doesn't make any sense.
So I would definitely go with no change
with no commas in it.
People who pursue careers
in transportation planning
have a wide variety of
educational backgrounds.
And then we can keep reading.
But obviously if you're under
time pressure for the SAT
you wouldn't necessarily
have to read all of this.
But between answering
all of these questions,
it's nice to be able to read all of this.
A two-year degree in
transportation technology
may be sufficient for
some entry-level jobs
in the field.
Most jobs, however, require
at least a bachelor's degree;
majors of transportation
planners are varied,
including fields such as urban
studies, civil engineering,
geography, or transportation
and logistics management.
For many positions in the field,
a master's degree is required.
So once again, if you
were doing this passage
you wouldn't really have
to read all of this.
you could have just tackled
this sentence by itself.
But if you have the
time it doesn't hurt to.
You might learn something about career
of transportation planning.
We're now on question six.
And there's a little bug here.
I'm using an early prototype
version of the software.
It' says question six of five.
It should be six of six, but anyway
I think we get the point.
Transportation planners
perform critical work
within the broader field of
urban and regional planning.
As of 2010, there were
approximately 40,300 urban
and regional planners
employed in the United States.
The United States Bureau of
Labor Statistics forecasts
steady job growth in this field,
projecting that 16 percent of
new jobs in all occupations
will be related to urban
and regional planning.
So grammatically that looks correct.
But then they have this chart down here,
and it says, Urban and Regional Planners
Predict Increase in Employment,
Projected 2010 to 2020.
And what they tell us about
urban and regional planners
is that between 2010 and
2020 there's going to be
a 16 percent increase in employment.
And so I think what's
going on here is that
this isn't about grammatically
fixing the sentence,
but actually seeing whether the meaning
of the sentence is correct.
So this says, projecting that 16 percent
of all new jobs, of new
jobs in all occupations
will be related to urban
and regional planning.
Is that what this is saying?
Is this 16 percent saying
the percent of all,
of new jobs in all occupations
that will be related
to urban and regional planning?
No, this 16 percent says it's the growth
in employment in urban
and regional planners.
It's not saying that
16 percent of all jobs
in all occupations will
be related to urban
and regional planning.
In fact, when you just
look at the raw number,
40,300 urban and regional
planners employed
in the United States,
that's way, way, way,
way, way less than 16 percent,
even if you have growth from 2010 to 2020.
So this sentence is just not right
when you look at this data.
They should be talking about
growth from 2010 to 2020.
It shouldn't be talking
about 16 percent of all jobs
are going to be related to urban planning.
So, let's see which of
these choices we'd go.
We definitely don't want to say no change
'cause we don't think that's right.
So we could say, warning, however,
that job growth in urban
and regional planning
will slow to 14 percent by 2020.
Well, I guess there's two issues here.
One, there's no data that
implies that the job growth
will slow to 14 percent by 2020.
And the other thing is the
idea of warning, however.
Somehow that this clause would contradict
what was just said.
The United States Bureau of
Labor Statistics forecasts
steady job growth in this
field, warning however,
that job growth in urban
and regional planning
will slow, I mean they
almost contradict each other.
The first part says that there's going
to be steady job growth.
And the second one says, warning, however,
that it's going to slow.
And there's no data to back this up.
Predicting that employment of urban
and regional planners
will increase 16 percent
between 2010 and 2020.
Well I think that's what this thing is,
this is what they're saying.
That you're going to have 16
percent increase in employment
between 2010 and 2020.
So that one looks very accurate.
It's actually what's being
described by this chart.
Indicating that 14 to 18 percent of urban
and regional planners, planning positions
will remain unfilled.
Well now, that's not what
this chart is telling us.
We don't have any data saying what percent
is going to be unfilled.
So I definitely wouldn't pick this.
So, we would say,
The United States Bureau
of Labor Statistics,
The United States Bureau of
Labor Statistics forecasts
steady job growth in this field,
predicting that employment
of urban and regional planners
will increase 16 percent
between 2010 and 2020.
Once again we changed it,
not because this sentence
was grammatically correct,
incorrect, but because this sentence...
not because this sentence
was grammatically incorrect,
but because it actually wasn't
consistent with the data.
Just wasn't right.
The meaning wasn't correct.
This C here has the correct meaning.